[Musique]
réd
turbulent là bas moi que si j'ai changé
je changeais taf
nous les 10 et ouvrant là voie pas
vraiment passé comme prévu
du coup je suis à nouveau chargé de
recrutement et si je devais me recruter
pour diriger société je réfléchirai à
deux fois 40 me non je rigole mais c'est
pas facile
depuis que c'était plus la star
on veut la traversée du désert ok je
comprends
non moi non plus je n'aurais pas
forcément envie d'adresser la parole à
quelqu'un qui est parti du jour au
lendemain sans donner d'explications
c'est tout ce que je mérite ans c'est à
dire rien à rien parce que je suis
qu'une merde
et merde bac tu envie de donner une
seconde chance à une merde
[Musique]
riant toujours aussi beau gosse tu leur
dis de s'abonner la chaîne multiprise
moi je comprends ce que tu baves asie 16
heures ok avec du sel dans le cul d'un
âne c'est craquer motive à bout
[Rires]
[Musique]